There’s been a lot of bombing:
Left right and above, everywhere.
It would be a lie to say I am not
afraid. Because this is a one-way ticket.
I know I’m going there for a good reason.
And if I don’t see my family, my friends
and the people I love here on this Earth again,
I have faith that I will meet them after death.
In Ukraine, it’s not just
Ukrainians who are fighting.
Thousands of people from abroad have joined the
battle. Who are they? Why are they doing it?
If I’m needed to help my comrades at
the frontline, I’ll go there. If I’m
needed to take care of civilians, I’ll do that.
Whatever job the legion gives me, I’ll do it.
Kapon,
as he calls himself, is from Latin America.
For security reasons we don’t disclose his
exact location. He is preparing to leave his
home. Kapon tells me he works as a paramedic.
He seems to have plenty of friends -
overall his life seems pretty normal to me.
He is one of several people I get
in touch with on social media.
Here people who want to join the Ukrainian
army connect from around the globe.
Quite a few men who say they are
already there, post about it.
But a lot of what they post is hard to verify.
In our first online encounter,
Kapon does not reveal his identity.
He wants to join the army as a combat medic.
I saw these terrible images of how they
attacked civilian zones with missiles,
people dying in their apartments, and attacks
against humanitarian corridors. I saw so many
terrible images of suffering civilians, including
children. And it broke my heart to see them.
And as a paramedic I have the skills to
help them. I know I have something to offer.
The 19-year-old tells me he
still lives with his parents.
He prefers to not share
pictures of his family though.
They don’t agree with what I’m
doing. The day before yesterday
my grandmother was crying. They’re afraid.
And I understand. I’m not going on a holiday,
I’m going to a country at war and will
risk my life to help other people.
He says his father even offered him money to stay.
But a few days later, it's time to leave.
His friends throw a farewell party.
He sends me videos from his journey: It’s
the first time that he is going abroad.
He doesn’t come from a rich
family. The mother of a friend
chips in to pay for the flight – in return
he has to promise to come back alive.
Sandra from Norway has already joined
the Ukrainian army, they refer me to her.
The life she depicts on social
media is not for the faint of heart.
She tells me, she used to be a fisher, then
served as a representative for her ethnic group,
the Sami people. She tells me that after
that, she trained as a combat medic.
Now, she says, she’s on the frontlines.
First of all, it's a moral obligation.
This is home base. It's in Europe.
So if you can help, you should.
She tells me what her days are like.
You can't really prepare because you
don't know what's going to happen.
There might be an airstrike and it might
be artillery and it might be relocating.
So you just have to run by it day by day.
On her social media account,
she poses with weapons.
She tells me she has no
qualms about firing her gun.
Well, it is what it is. It's your
job. It's what you have to do. So
it's the one who fires first. That's
how it goes. We are not the attackers.
We are the defenders. We are not the
one crossing any borders, they did.
Kapon flies to Krakow in Poland,
close to the Ukrainian border.
Temperatures in eastern Europe just have
dipped to near freezing - a climate that
Kapon has never experienced before. I
join him for the next leg of his journey
First stop: A military shop.
He still needs a bullet-proof vest,
since he isn’t sure whether the
international legion provides one.
Do you have body armor? No? But
another body armor you have?
No
Five point eleven?
No, no, no, we don’t have.
The military shops in Krakow
are overrun right now.
What are you going to do?
Well, apparently, it’s difficult
to find body armor in Krakow.
I have to go without one, and
hope that I don’t get shot at.
Isn’t that a suicide mission?
A bit.
It would be good to have one. But even
with a vest, the bullets come through.
So the only thing I can do is
hope to come back in one piece.
By chance, Kapon meets some British
men who also want to join the battle.
We go today.
Ah, today, ok.
Medic?
Yes, Paramedic.
To me, he makes a dubious impression.
Killer.
Killer. Killer. Killer.
The man doesn’t want to be filmed – but
claims he fought in Iraq and Afghanistan,
working for a private military contractor.
Kapon has no combat experience, so he decides
to train on a shooting range. He is now joined
by a man from Colombia who goes by Tato. They met
online in a group of Spanish-speaking volunteers.
They also test an AK 47, which
is being used in Ukraine.
The training at the shooting range is intended
for civilians and is supposed to be just for fun.
It’s just the second time that Kapon
has ever held a gun, he tells me
After half an hour he’s done.
It doesn’t prepare me for war as such,
but at least I know a how to handle a weapon
correctly, that I might use in Ukraine.
For people like Kapon, the international
legion is their main port of call in Ukraine.
On Instagram it advertises itself as an
adventurous, heroic group of comrades.
It was founded just days after the war started
and is believed to have around 20 000 members.
According to the legion, they are paid the
equivalent of Ukrainian soldiers of their
rank – sometimes less than 500 Euros a month.
Their contract lasts until the war is over.
Their spokesperson tells me, that people who want
to join have to pass several tests in Ukraine.
As a rule, they are sent to some of
the hottest spots on the front line
and are taken care of in some very, let's say,
delicate, offensive and defensive operations.
Can you prove that you don't
use them as cannon fodder?
Well, I think it is difficult for anyone to prove
anything in this war. What I can say is that
we can give all public and private assurances
that no one in the Army is interested in
sending people to the front who are not ready.
The Russian government sees the
international fighters as mercenaries,
which would violate international law and could
result in worse treatment if they are captured.
I ask an expert for his opinion.
They are not mercenaries. It's not a
company. It's not a commercial entity
which is sending those fighters
there. There is quite a difference.
And as long as they are integrated into the forces
of the host country, they are not mercenaries.
Is this phenomenon of international
fighters that we see right now in Ukraine,
is this something new or has this always been
present also during other kinds of conflicts?
No, it’s not new. We've seen this in Afghanistan,
in Iraq and other Middle Eastern countries.
But to make the distinction clear, when
those Islamist fighters joined an insurgency,
it's completely different from joining
the ranks of an existing country.
In Poland I meet a German soldier
who tells me he has been in Ukraine
for 2 weeks. He wants to go
back to Ukraine with his dog.
Poland seems to be a jumping-off point for
foreign volunteers. In total I talk to 7 of
them on and offline. Much of what they say is hard
to verify. Some of the men don’t appear credible,
their mental or social condition appears
unstable. A man from Estonia, who claims he
is at the front suddenly ends our contact, which
worries me. I am not sure what happened to him.
I join Kapon and Tato on their way to the border.
The international legion officially only accepts
people with live combat experience – but they give
it a try anyway. Tato at least served for 8 years
in the Colombian military, he says. Recently he
was working in Spain, but lost his job. For
him, the war is also a career opportunity.
Why is it worth taking this risk? I often
ask myself that and don’t have an answer.
I think it’s also the excitement, the
adrenaline. It’s a chance to prove myself.
I think about it constantly and feel nervous.
I’d be lying if I said I wasn’t afraid,
but with this fear comes adrenaline.
Time for the last voice message:
I want you to know that I am ok. I love
you. I’ll send you a message when I can.
After death, I think god will judge us, for
what we did in life, whether it was good or bad.
I’m grateful to my family that
they introduced me to Catholicism.
My faith gives me hope and keeps me safe.
I know that I am going there for a good reason.
And if I don’t see my family and my friends
and the people I love here on this earth
again, I hope I will meet them after death.
The man who sits next to them is from Ukraine.
That’s your family?
Yes, that’s my family.
They are still in Ukraine. He’s going to the
border to get his mother and bring her to safety.
His brother and cousin are at the front, he tells
me. So what does he think of the foreign fighters?
It good, they do a good job
for the peace in the world
and for peace in Ukraine. We cannot stop
this war by ourselves. We need help.
This is the way to the border.
Most people are going the opposite direction:
More than 5 million Ukrainians
have left their country so far.
I’m really cold and a bit nervous. Now that I see
the people here, the volunteers, the soldiers,
the families crossing the border I’m even
more motivated and excited than I was before.
Does he really think he can
change the course of the war?
I’m not Rambo, nothing special.
But each grain of sand helps.
And if I just save the life of a few
fighters, I’ll have achieved change.
They want to join the
international legion the next day.
My journey with them ends here,
but they promise to stay in touch.
I head back to Germany. I’m still in contact with
several people on their way to the international
legion. Some of them turn around the last minute.
And I receive sad news: The man from Estonia,
who said he was at the front and then stopped
communicating with me is no longer alive:
His brother tells me, he returned home, but
then killed himself. His brother tells me
he suffered from mental illness. He seemed to be
mentally unstable. Shortly before his suicide,
he apparently watched video clips of the war.
Sandra, who has been at the front for quite some
time, is still there and determined to stay.
Sandra:
There’s been a lot of bombing, left right and
above, everywhere. You get used to that, too.
The human brain is wired to just get used to
whatever situation you have to get used to.
And I know that sounds weird, but you can
get used to anything, including bombing.
Yeah. When do you think? Will you be back home?
I will be back when this war is over. When there's
no more need for me here, then I will go home.
Kapon seems to have a bit of a rollercoaster
ride. The international legion at first rejects
him and several others. But 10 days later he
tells me the legion suddenly did accept him.
He writes ‘I am happy’ and sends me a
picture of the body armour he was given.
On Instagram, he posts you are the only one
who can make all of your dreams come true.
Besides paramedic tasks, he now seems to be
receiving regular combat training in order
to defend himself. In a few days,
he could be sent to the front.
We agree that for security reasons
this will be our last interview.
They will train me for combat,
with real ammunition, everything.
Have you thought about leaving?
You do think about it when you hear detonations,
when you’re close to exploding grenades,
when you hear sirens and are in the
cold for hours, wearing just a sweater.
Also, I haven’t showered in a week, since
there’s no bathroom. So you do start to think.
Has your view of this war changed?
Yes. I realized it’s even worse
than what you see on the news.
Everything is worse, because you’re
the main target. It’s quite ugly.
It’s a strange feeling to say goodbye and I
hope he will make it back home in one piece.